buenas noches pues emanuel manjón
respondió a todas las preguntas que
lograron hacerle durante una hora y
treinta que duró ese evento de campaña
en cuasi una población a unos 30
kilómetros al oeste de parís más allá de
responder acerca de preguntas sobre lo
que está sucediendo entre ucrania y
rusia sobre el poder adquisitivo que se
estaba viendo bastante afectado por las
fuertes alzas de los precios de la
gasolina y también de la energía pues
fue también la ocasión para él de hablar
de los cuatro pilares de su programa de
gobierno para los próximos cinco años un
programa de gobierno que él todavía no
ha desvelado cuatro pilares que él llamó
pactos pacto republicano cuando habla de
inmigración de seguridad pacto por la
defensa europea pacto de productividad y
también pacto de generaciones cuando
habla en materia de educación y también
de salud esta fue la oportunidad para él
de hablar de todo esto pero también fue
un ejercicio un poquito de equilibrista
para el presidente ma con que algunas
veces hablaba como ma con candidato y
otras veces como ma como presidente y el
mismo pues les explicó a los presentes
que era un poco esa dualidad en la que
ahora mismo y precisamente hablando de
esa dualidad la campaña de manuel más
como se está viendo beneficiada de la
guerra en ucrania
pues lo cierto es que el presidente va a
tener va a contar con mucha más
exposición mediática porque habrán que
hacer la diferencia a los medios tendrán
que hacer la diferencia en el momento en
que de manuel ma con hable como
presidente y enmanuel ma con hable como
candidato y precisamente con esto pues
que se está viviendo actualmente es algo
que va a comenzar a suceder sobre todo a
partir de hoy cuando comience ya a
contabilizarse el tiempo de uso de la
palabra los diferentes candidatos a esta
elección presidencial ya lo decían desde
la semana pasada que tenían mucho que
esto fuera a suceder que todo lo que
está sucediendo en términos de
geopolítica pues fuera a acaparar a
eclipsar la campaña es algo que ha
venido sucediendo y bueno si lo ha
beneficiado en todo caso los últimos
sondeos han demostrado que de manuel
marco ha ganado cuatro puntos en la
intención de voto y los sondeos que los
siguen dando como ganador tanto en la
primera como en la segunda vuelta atrás